What's up wisecrack Michael again. So I'm just going to come out and say it.
Sometimes I pined for my awkward teen years in the early two thousands,
it was a simpler time. If you will, a time when frosted tips were cool,
a cop wouldn't kill you.
And the words murder and Hornet never appeared in a sentence together.
And perhaps most importantly,
it was a time before Disney and JJ Abrams got their hands on star Wars.
Now that's not to say George Lucas hit it out of the park a hundred percent of
the time, because well, he didn't.
But despite the constant pre-qual bashing,
I have a certain fondness for episode three. Sure. It's not perfect,
but it truly strove for greatness like Greek drama greatness complete with
larger than life characters, ancient prophecies,
and a lot of severed hands just in a galaxy far, far away.
And while the film is certainly no masterpiece,
it can actually teach us a lot about one of literature's most demanding John was
graduating. So join me for this wisecrack edition on star Wars, episode three,
crafting a tragedy and spoilers ahead.
Before we dive deeper into star Wars,
I wanted to let you guys know that if you were itching from our wisecrack
content, we have two podcasts that currently run all year long. First,
every other Friday,
you have shown me the meaning hosted by your favorite redhead,
where the crew discusses the philosophy and deeper meaning of all your favorite
films.
They've covered everything from the matrix of Django and chain to mean girls and
cats. Then every other Wednesday, wisecrack writer,
Alec and widespread researcher,
Serbia joined me and exploring the weird depths of the internet and society and
culture of binge.
You can find links to our shows in the video description to make things even
easier. You can watch the video version of the strains on our YouTube channel,
youtube.com/wise cast. Check them out and leave a comment.
You may just end up on the pod. Now back to the show. First,
a quick refresher after a separatist movement leaves the galactic Republic
embroiled in war chancellor, Palpatine,
the de facto head of the Republic ending not so secret.
Sith Lord gets folk captured by general grievous and the separatists obiwan and
Anna can make a desperate bid to free the chancellor,
which leads to more severed hands and one murder count when they return home
anagen receives a hero's welcome,
whereas that his wife is pregnant and then gets appointed to the Jedi council.
All's well, that ends well, right?
Not quite as the clone Wars draw to a close chancellor,
Palpatine solidifies his power in the Senate and the Jedi council grows
distrustful of antiquing friendship with them worse. And it can,
is played by prophetic dreams of Padma dying dreams that Palpatine.
Yeah, I had such a knowledge of the dark side.
He could even keep the ones he cared about
from dying.
Well, Anacon initially snitches on the chancellor for being a Sith.
The young Skywalker eventually betrays the Jedi council and hopes of saving
Padma Palpatine. Then executes the infamous order,
66 to exterminate all the Jedi.
Execute all the 66.
And turns the galactic Republic into galactic empire bestowing upon us.
One of our all time. Favorite memes,
The film concludes with antique and spiraling into darkness,
killing innocent children and forge choking Padma before facing obiwan in one
final Epic fight. The rest is history and it can is defeated.
Padma dies in childbirth and Darth Vader. As we know him is born.
[Inaudible].
I to understand how George Lucas crafted a modern tragedy out of episode three
and how it felt just short of greatness.
We first have to look at the genre itself in his book,
poetics Aristotle defines a tragedy as a story about one rate individual who
experiences a reversal of fortune, thereby evoking, pity,
or fear in the audience. And yes,
episode three checks all these boxes and can thought to be the child of prophecy
and destined for greatness falls to the dark side and destroys everything he
loved. We feel bad for him. It's not.
[Inaudible].
Want to get into the real nuts and bolts of the tragedy when you don't where a
structural definition of the term literary critic,
Christopher Booker offers this definition of tragedy in his absolute brick of a
text. The seven basic plots,
a tragedy is the story of a hero being tempted or impelled into a course of
action, which is in some way,
dark or forbidden for a time as the hero embarks on her course,
he enjoys almost unbelievable dreamlike success,
but somehow the original dream has soured into a nightmare where everything is
going more and more wrong. This eventually culminates in the heroes,
violent destruction to Booker this arc from temptation to destruction,
spans five simple steps. Importantly, we see aniguns arc and episode three,
match this structure. Step first step, we start with stage one,
the anticipation stage.
This is the start of our journey where we find our tragic hero,
unfulfilled and dreaming of greater things.
As Booker as quick to point out this isn't all that different from how our
traditional non tragic heroes start their stories and non tragic episode four.
For example,
we opened with a simple farmhand dreaming of adventure and episode three,
we opened with a dissatisfied hero who feels stifled by his superiors as a
result he's pathologically reckless
And the first battle he disobeyed his orders and tries to shoot off the drones,
swarming Obi-Wan ship. Then in a true hold my shotgun moment,
and it can tries to use his own ship to scoop them off. Of course,
we will learn that Anna can only take such dumb,
dumb risks in order to save his loved ones,
but there's a darker component to this and it can has ambition. He wants power.
We see this in a showdown with count Duku.
Anger.
And this is what sets the tragic hero apart from our traditional hero,
instead of answering your typical call to adventure like Luke answering Leah's
distress signal, the tragic hero answers a different call,
the call to temptation.
We see Anna can answer this call when he listens to chancellor Palpatine and
kills count, Duku.
Go kill him.
It fills us with dress. This is the first step in Anna Ken's fall.
He's given into his desire for power here. The temptations of the Sith, Trump,
the teachings of the Jetta. This brings us to stage two.
The dream stage Booker defines the dream stage as the point where the tragic
hero, but comes in some way committed to his course of action. And for a while,
things go almost improbably well for the hero he is winning the gratification.
He had dreamed up and seems to be getting away with it for Anik.
And this means getting exactly what he wants. He's become a hero.
His new bestie Palpatine is back in power and he scores a seat on the Jedi
council. Of course not. Everyone is happy with these developments,
particularly Anik and fellow Jetta,
but our young Skywalker just doesn't care so long as he can save. Padma,
Booker might call these events. Typical dream stage fare.
The tragic hero remains reckless in their pursuit of their goal and is blinded
enough by their subsequent success so much so that they don't realize they're
sowing the seeds of their own destruction.
This is doubly the case for Aniket who is so blinded by the power of Palpatine
offers him that he doesn't realize he's slipping towards the dark side.
And ironically do mean both Padma and himself.
Next up is stage three.
The frustration stage when the tide begins to shift against our tragic hero.
At this point in the journey,
Booker says the tragic hero begins to experience a sense of frustration.
And in order to secure, his position may feel compelled to further dark acts,
which lock him into his course of action,
even more irrevocably and episode three.
And it can becomes increasingly frustrated with the limitations of his new found
success. While he might sit on the Jedi council,
his fellow Jedi will neither grant him the rank of master nor help him save
Padma.
And when Anna can seize another vision of Padma dying this time with OB one,
by her side,
his frustration hits its peak fed up with the Jedi and tempted by Palpatine.
And it can ops to save the chancellor at the last minute and a fit of
desperation.
He lops off hand number three while mace Windu is forced lightening out the
window and saving Palpatine anagen. Finally commits that irrevocable act.
The one which seals his fate as if to underscore this point,
Palpatine tells Anacon.
I learned with his transpired here, they will kill us.
And those foreboding words bring us to stage four,
the nightmare stage in which the tragic hero finds himself alone with the forces
of opposition, arrayed firmly against him.
That's exactly where Anna can lands after he betrays the Jedi order and murders.
The last of the separatists in the most of our system,
only for Padma to confront him in what amounts to a truly unhinged rant.
And again, admits to killing children and the separatists alike,
all for pad may sick to see. We.
Don't have to run away anymore. I have brought peace to the Republic.
I am more powerful than the chancellor. I can overthrow him
and together you and I can rule the galaxy,
make things the way we want them to be.
In doing so.
And it can push us away his last and closest ally and any real hope of
redemption when Obi wan steps out of the ship and it can misconstrues this all
as an elaborate plot to kill him and a desperate bid for control of the
situation. He breaks out his soon to be signature,
move the force choke the only problem it's on his wife.
This bleakly transitions us into stage five.
The destruction or death wish stage in which our tragic hero will finally
destroy himself isolated from all his friends and family.
The end is now in sight for Anna and after a heated lightsaber duel with obiwan
the two stare each other down over a lava river.
That's when this iconic exchange goes down.
Veronica, I have the high ground.
You underestimate my power. Try it.
Remember that.
Pride and ambition that led Anak and to kill count Duku and court Palpatine's
friendship here.
It leads him to believe that he can finally take down his former master,
even with a fatal disadvantage. So how does that go for him? Yeah.
And it can more like Anna can't insure and it can doesn't experience a
literal death here,
but as he burns on the lava shores of Mustafar cursing his old master,
it's hard not to feel that the boy we met in episode one is metaphorically debt
fittingly in the closing scene of the film.
He's reborn as the most iconic villain in cinema history.
But here's the question. Wisecrack,
if episode three stuck so closely to Booker's five-part structure,
why does it still seem like it's messing up this whole tragedy thing? Now,
maybe this is a lot to ask of the only decent film in a trilogy,
otherwise mired by mediocrity and sand. I don't like sand,
but in all seriousness, we think that film fails into key components of tragedy,
one,
the dramatic flaw and two destiny and how they both interact with this five-part
structure.
The concept of the tragic flaw also comes from you guessed it Aristotle,
which translated into its original Greek [inaudible] means to miss the Mark fall
short or aired.
And Aristotle's conception of the term hamartoma is the mistake in judgment that
sets our tragic hero on their path and ultimately dooms them and edit is Rex
it's edifices, incessant desire. For knowledge at first,
this desire brings some results. He solves the riddle of the Sphinx,
saves thieves and becomes King, but this desire also guarantees his downfall.
When the place starts at Episys searching for the murderer of the previous King.
So he can stop a plague from ravaging his city, except in this relentless quest,
for knowledge,
he misses the Mark by which we mean Oedipus realizes that he killed the King.
His father banged the queen, his mother, and is truly,
and literally blind to the cosmic truth of the world. Importantly,
this tragic flaw orders, the action of the story, all of the characters,
mistakes are born out of this deficiency as they emotionally spiral into
despair. This flaw only skyrockets and intensity,
which is how we get our tragic arc. The problem with episode three though,
is that this tragic flaw is a lot harder to pin down, simply put, and it can,
doesn't merely miss the Mark in one way, he's angry, he's proud, he's ambitious.
And sometimes he's just an all around and in the philosophy of the forest,
it's all kind of a packaged deal. And yes, before you smash that like button,
I know the film goes to great lengths to explain all these disparate flaws is
the outgrowth of one underpinning flaw fear.
We can see this in both Yoda's warnings.
They're full, you must be winching the future. And again,
the fear of loss is a path to the dark side.
As well as in Duke who's ramblings.
Woke.
Whether it's the Jedi or the Sith, it seems like everyone agrees.
That fear is the gateway drug to a lot of bad emotions.
Except when we sit down to analyze the film fear alone,
doesn't really motivate a lot of anecdotes, mistakes,
at least not in the same way, edifice,
his desire for knowledge motivates his mistakes as a result. And again,
his emotional journey reads a bit uneven at times to see what I mean.
Let's revisit Booker's five part structure and see how Anna Cannes tragic floss
was back and forth between these steps and the anticipation stage.
We identified a lust for power and ambition as the tragic flaw that made Annie
can kill count Duca, but then there's this line.
Hey, cut off your arm. You wanted revenge.
Okay.
So you're probably thinking aniguns lust for power with a side of revenge is his
tragic flaw. But then in the dream stage,
most of the conflict centers around anti-guns moral discomfort over plain spy
for the Jedi.
You're asking me to do something against the Jedi code against the Republic
against a mentor and a friend that's what's out of place here.
His misplaced loyalties would drive to the plot here,
not his desire for power in the ensuing frustration stage.
This misplaced loyalty is further tested until eventually Anacon chooses
Palpatine. Remember Palpatine is a trader,
so it's not loyalty motivating this decision.
Instead it can chooses the dark side because he fears losing Padma,
which really has nothing to do with this ambition. So far,
his tragic flaw has gone from lust for power to misplace loyalty,
to fear of losing his BU of course, this fear seems pretty short-lived though,
because Anacon has no problem choking Padma in the nightmare stage. Yeah.
We're back to power lust again,
complete now with ramblings about ruling an empire,
this flaw carries onto the destruction stage and then credits.
I should note here,
each of these flaws individually makes plenty of logical sense and it can,
penis has been foreshadowed and explained throughout the trilogy.
He has a bad temper.
Doesn't like sand obsesses over losing his loved ones and does a war in episode
two, but it doesn't entirely work in the narrative sense.
It feels more sloppy than complex because the tragic flaw changes so drastically
throughout the film. We,
as the audience are left with a bit of an emotional whiplash take, for example,
the nightmare stage in which Anna can,
is all about that power so much so that he actually slaughters a bunch of
Jedi children just so we can get more of it to a lot of movie goers at the time,
this offscreen revelation was a shocker and not in a good way.
It just seems so far out of character from the anecdote we knew up to this
point, the paddle on losing his temper shirt, acting in revenge,
find vainly seeking glory. Yeah. Going too far to defend those.
He cares about definitely murdering kids to get a promotion of
whats,
but that's because the tragic flaw motivating this action wasn't consistent in
the buildup and a can spear was played up in the last stage and is misplaced
loyalty in the stage before.
But imagine how powerful the scene would be at every stage mannequin's journey
was motivated by one flaw, say the fear of loss.
Imagine if he had killed count Duku in order to save OB one,
she had against the council out of fear that their plans would cost more lives.
If killing mace Windu directly and immediately saved Padma, which is to say,
imagine of all of these tragic stages expounded upon this same flaw.
If mannequins visions of a dime pad may involve her house burning down from a
young leans flaming bag of doorstep, poop, prank, gone wrong,
then maybe the outrageous step of hurting children in the nightmare stage
wouldn't seem so outrageous.
The message being that if you're willing to go to any length to save the ones
you love, no matter what you risk becoming a monster.
According to Booker this inevitable slide from good to bad from the light side
to the dark side is the key component of the tragic heroes personality.
They are a divided self, one part of their personality,
striving against another,
and their downfall amounts to the process whereby a human being may be
transformed into a monster, but it's not enough for antique.
And to simply become a monster.
He has to become one of the greatest villains of cinematic history while his
lack of a consistent tragic flaw makes for a less satisfying one-off tragedy.
There would also be a problem if his tragic flaw was consistent specifically,
it's possible.
We might relate or even empathize too heavily with diluting the power of the
monster. We know he becomes because, and it can,
can't just be a good guy who happened to go down the wrong path.
He has to be extra bad.
This isn't your average everyday darkness.
This is an advanced darkness.
That brings us to our final. And in this case, complicated component of tragedy,
fate and akin, and more sense than one was faded to be bad.
This is consistent with classic tragedy where a pervasive sense of inevitability
hangs above heroes,
whether it's Oedipus or Macbeth characters are not only doomed by prophecies,
but often by their very nature of flaws that forced these prophecies to come
true. But for Anacon, as we discussed this dreaded inevitability,
doesn't come from a single tragic flaw that renders him sympathetic. Instead,
our dread comes primarily from the fact that we,
the audience already know is fake because all the Greeks might've believed in
the literal spinners of fate controlling destiny in the star Wars fandom,
we believe in an even greater guy, the Holy Trinity of episodes, four, five,
and six that's where episode three's missteps become more forgivable deep
above all else. Lucas had to preserve the integrity of this sacred sank trilogy.
Even if it came at the cost of Anna Ken's character arc. In episode three,
if the film had doubled down on anti-guns fear of loss for his tragic flaw,
he might've joined the Pantheon of other great tragic curios and pop culture
from Michael Corleone until Walter White,
as with our other family mentoring crime bosses,
our hearts would break even more when we see Anik and go past the point of no
return and in doing so, we'd experienced the ultimate aim of tragedy,
emotional release or catharsis,
but making anecdote a full tragic hero would inherently ruin a more important
character. Darth Vader, our OJI villain, a tragic hero. We pity a villain.
We love to Hayden maybe eventually learn to love when he redeemed himself and
Anna kin by virtue of episodes,
four through six was doomed to start off as a very hateable villain.
So what do you think wisecrack does the overwhelming salients of Darth Vader,
the villain doom, Anik, and the tragic hero,
or are we being too hard on this ambitious film?
Let us know what you think in the comments. Many,
many thanks to our rad patrons for supporting us.
Thanks for watching guys later.
[Inaudible].